thank you
[Music]
this is your Tech news briefing for
Friday September 23rd I'm Zoe Thomas for
The Wall Street Journal
once seen as a tool for spies or
whistleblowers virtual private networks
or vpns are now used by companies
families and individuals just looking to
protect their privacy
but just because vpns keep your data
hidden from some people who might want
it doesn't mean your data is always
private and there may be sometimes when
you may not need one to keep you safe
online at all wsj personal Tech reporter
Dalvin Brown wrote about vpns the best
ways to use them and their possible
downsides and he joins me now hi Dalvin
thanks for joining me of course thanks
for having me so start us off with some
Basics what is a VPN what does it do
yeah so a VPN is a virtual private
Network and essentially it does just
that it creates a private Channel over
the open web for your data it encrypts
your data and turns it into gibberish so
that third parties can't see it and if
they do happen to hack into servers
where your data is it will be illegible
essentially and the process protects
your data from your internet service
provider but it also masks your search
history and the websites and apps you're
using from hackers
okay so say I'm considering using a VPN
when would be the right time to start
using one
yeah so I will say it's questionable
whether everyone needs a VPN because a
lot of websites have encryption already
built in so websites with https will
kind of protect people from having their
data snooped on by Third parties or
their internet service provider with
that said there are scenarios that a VPN
might be useful to you so for one if
you're traveling abroad and you have
Netflix for instance and you want to be
able to access your content abroad a VPN
might help you do that if you're also
just worried about what information your
internet service provider has on you a
VPN can help with that and there's also
some protections like I said against
hackers where you know if you're using a
public Wi-Fi network and you're afraid
or someone might be snooping or you just
want to prevent that from happening a
VPN might be useful to you
okay so a VPN is going to protect my
data from an outsider who wants to look
at it but does the VPN have access to it
yeah so it's a catch-22 if you sign up
for a VPN you're certainly shielding
your information from a lot of people
but the VPN provider does have access to
what you're doing online
what you want to look for then is what
their logs policy is some have no logs
policy which means they do not log your
information or they'll explicitly say
how long they hold on to your browser
Data before deleting it so those are two
things that you really want to pay
attention to when you're picking a VPN
are there other possible downsides to
using a VPN versus maybe not using it
yeah so after publishing this story some
readers wrote in talking about how
difficult it was to log into their bank
account online for instance when they
had a VPN activated which makes sense if
your bank thinks you're in another
country they may not allow you to sign
it there's also limitations with
streaming so streaming platforms like
Netflix
are sort of fighting an uphill battle
against vpns so while your VPN may allow
you to stream content internationally
today or a specific show you want to see
internationally today it may not be able
to tomorrow as Netflix and other
companies work to to circumvent this
what about the costs of them because I
mean this is something you're paying for
right
yeah you don't want to use a free VPN at
least that's what cyber Security Experts
told me the companies that are offering
vpns for free have to make money some
way and you don't want them to make
money by selling your data so you would
want to go with one that you're paying
for prices run the gamut but going with
a company that has been in the business
for at least 10 years or longer is a
safer way to go and then you can decide
whether you want to pay monthly for a VM
VPN service or whether you want to pay
annually and if you pay for your VPN
you're more likely to get other useful
features like kill switches that will
turn off your internet connection the
moment your data isn't into end
encrypted so you get added benefits if
you pay for a VPN service that you
probably won't get if you're going with
a free one
Delvin I feel like we've heard a lot
more about vpns over the last year or so
between companies using them more with
workers being remote and also with the
war in Ukraine we've heard about people
in Russia maybe using them to get around
some of the restrictions on the internet
there is that changing at all how vpns
work or the way governments might crack
down on them governments can and have
certainly cracked down on people using
vpns your internet service provider
knows when you are using a VPN and so if
you're in a country where your internet
service provider is the government then
certainly there are risks there but
people continue to use them particularly
in countries with strict censorship to
to get around that and to access
information that's more widely available
on the internet and so if you have any
concerns about the government any
concerns about hackers or any concerns
about really anyone other than the VPN
provider peeping in then a VPN is one
thing to consider all right that was our
personal Tech reporter Dalvin Brown
Dalvin thanks for joining us thank you
and that's it for Tech news briefing
this week Julie Chang is our producer
Chris sinsley is our supervising
producer our executive producer is
Katara Yocum I'm your host Zoe Thomas
thanks for listening and have a great
weekend
foreign
[Music]